oh
[Musique]
où
la plage de tijuana est un lieu irréel
pour quiconque le découvre comme moi
pour la première fois s'est étendue
infinie face aux pacific est coupé par
deux aux barreaux métalliques
c'est ici que commence le mur qui marque
la frontière entre le mexique et les
états unis longtemps cette frontière a
été délimité par le simple tas de
pierres
aujourd'hui des barrières conçu pour
arrêter tout être vivant plus gros qu'un
lièvre sépare les deux pays
les murs coupe des villes en deux passes
parfois au milieu d'un jardin public
sione des collines bucolique l'objectif
des américains est de réduire
l'immigration illégale et les trafics
venus d'amérique latine
[Musique]
les mexicains de tijuana viennent en
famille péché pique nique les cheminots
l'ambiance est joyeuse et bon enfant
côté californien des ballets
d'hélicoptères de quad et de quatre
cadres de la police des frontières
surveillera no-man's-land de plusieurs
kilomètres tout est prêt pour la chasse
à l'homme derrière l'objectif de mon
appareil photo je remarque un homme
debout entre deux barreaux sa posture et
son attitude m'interpelle
il étudie la partie américaine de la
plage
j'ai traversé plusieurs fois mon
objectif est d'essayer encore mais c'est
compliqué maintenant c'est fait quatre
jours que j'observe l'instant la
technologie
comment sont placés les choses le
gouvernement américain connaît bien tout
cela j'ai déjà traversé jusqu'à
l'endroit où l'eau la can le net c'est
le plus loin je suis parviennent ils à
des checkpoints l'on peut être localisé
en fait il faut qu'il y ait de la brume
car avec de la bruine
de loin on ne voit plus
j'ai réussi à traverser une fois comme
ça donc je suis sûr que ça peut marcher
il ya à tijuana une population flottante
des dizaines peut être des centaines de
milliers de migrants vivent là sans être
vraiment installés dans la ville
certains sont en route vers les états
unis
d'autres reviennent expulsés de force
par les autorités californiennes
la casa del migrante fondée par des
missionnaires en 1985 accueillent tous
ces hommes en errance derrière ses
portes
le rencontrons un jeune guatémaltèque
cela fait trois mois et 15 jours qu'il
est parti de chez lui avec l'espoir de
rejoindre chicago
[Musique]
je suis arrivé en train caché dans un
train de marchandises et je suis venu
ici j'ai préféré éviter l'autobus
on peut être arrêté par les douaniers
mexicain qui nous expulse au guatemala
c'était dur à cause des voleurs de l'eau
on dort pas si dieu le veut je voudrais
rejoindre les états unis on m'avait
parlé de la casa del migrante et c'est
bien qu'ils aient des endroits comme ça
je viens d'amérique centrale et je n'ai
aucun lieu pour me reposer
c'est donc un vrai réconfort pour moi
d'être ici
compagnie j'ai peur je ne vais pas vous
dire le contraire
j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya des voleurs à
la frontière aussi avoir des problèmes
avec les narcotrafiquants streetpass de
la drogue vers les états unis
oui j'ai peur qu'ils m'attrapent est
possible est la mienne ils veulent me
frapper le fait du chantage pour qu
apporte le danger et candidats au départ
sont prêts à risquer leur vie pour se
rendre aux états unis
la présence du mur et des technologies
de surveillance mise en place par les
américains les pousse à s'enfoncer
toujours plus loin dans le désert il
marche de nuit pour éviter de soleil
brûlant et parce qu'il ya moins de
risques de se faire repérer
cette traversée dure deux jours au
minimum est souvent quatre la
déshydratation
l'épuisement et la maladie sont leurs
pires ennemis depuis 1994 plus de 5600
migrants ayant trouvé la mort
nous traversons la frontière une simple
formalité avec nos passeports français
nous voilà en californie la différence
de richesse avec le mexique est
frappante
ici le niveau de vie est trois fois
supérieur je comprends les espoirs des
migrants
à san diego j'ai pris contact avec un
briquet boulonnaise
son association les anges de la
frontière des pousses des bouteilles
d'eau dans le désert informe les
migrants de leurs droits et pour les
familles mexicaines sont nouvelles
[Musique]
enrique morones s est né à san diego un
territoire mexicain
andy car la californie fut mexicaine
jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle
cet homme énergique a fait de l'aide aux
migrantes son combat reconnu comme l'un
des 100 latino les plus influents aux
états unis elle intervient régulièrement
sur les plateaux de télévision et même
un fort lobbying politique en faveur
d'une réforme migratoire
les etats-unis ont construit le mur en
94 beaucoup de gens ont commencé à un ou
deux morts par mois à la frontière entre
san diego et brésil c'est maintenant 2 à
3 personnes qui meurent chaque jour
[Musique]
nous nous rendons avec enrique morones s
harold ville une petite ville au milieu
des collines à une quinzaine de
kilomètres de la frontière
le cimetière communal les autorités
américaines en terre les corps non
identifiés qu'elle retrouve dans le
désert monsieur enrique morones s j'ai
reçu avec une douleur immense votre
lettre je ne parviens pas à accepter la
mort de mon cher fils marcel hinault
martin que puis je dire à propos de mon
fils c'était un homme le garçon
travailleur honnête il souhaitait
réussir et connaître les états unis ce
pays tant désirée par de nombreux jeunes
sa mort met en veille j'ai une douleur
dans mon coeur et dans mon âme est rien
il avait 19 ans et comme on dit il
commençait tout juste à vivre les
etats-unis m promouvoir les droits de
l'homme
ils en parlent mais ne les appliquent
pas ils ont dit qu'il fallait construire
le mur pour arrêter les migrants pour
arrêter la drogue pour arrêter toutes
sortes de trafics
mais comme l'a dit le président kennedy
litres et moins un mur de 50 pieds et je
vous montrerai une échelle de 5 ans perd
pied en fait chacun nous a le pouvoir de
faire changer les choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux états unis il y a ceux qui sont
révoltés par les conditions inhumaines
auxquels se confrontent les migrants
après tout ce pays ne s'est il pas
construit grâce à l'immigration
[Musique]
mais il ya aussi depuis 2001 une
tentation de repli nationaliste très
forte à deux pas du mexique
glenn spencer le fondateur de
l'association american border patrol
nous attendons sa propriété au coeur de
la syrah verne
j'appréhende un peu notre rencontre avec
ce rappel extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique américain
je suis propriétaire de la maison qui
est surplombée par la tour de
surveillance sky road
[Musique]
pour lui le mur est un minimum pour
garantir des bonnes relations avec les
mexicains son association financée par
des dons de citoyens américains oeuvre
pour le renforcement de la sécurité de
la frontière claire spencer est persuadé
que l'importance de l'immigration
clandestine menace l'avenir des états
unis je suis venu ici et c'est ans et
avait pas de mur c'est bien la raison
pour laquelle je me suis installé en
arizona c'était pour obtenir
on construit un mur avec des commerçants
ligue quand on atteint un certain âge on
s'implique en politique on s'investit
dans quelque chose pas du tout pour
faire de l'argent peut faire autre chose
beaucoup de gens s'approprient une cause
certaines les diabétiques
d'autres préfèrent sauver les baleines
ou défendre une autre cause moi j'ai
choisi de faire face
[Applaudissements]
les bonnes d'arrière fond les bons
voisins les migrants ne font rien de mal
à part qu'ils traversent la frontière
illégalement à les refaire avec notre
avion on les suit et on fait un rapport
pour la police des frontières
l'idée selon laquelle on serait une fac
schiste est stupide si on est une
association high tech qui informe les
citoyens américains de ce qui se passe
réellement à la frontière et de ce qu'il
est nécessaire de mettre en oeuvre pour
glen spencer la sécurité nationale passe
avant tout les associations comme la
sienne sont nombreuses aux états unis et
profitent souvent d'un amalgame grossier
entre immigration terrorisme et trafic
de drogue dans la tête de ces radicaux
un modeste migrants avec un sac à dos
devient vite un dangereux
narcotrafiquants
une car à nolhac aucun mur ne pourrez
combattre
[Musique]
à tijuana tout le monde a une histoire
un lien avec la ligne à comme on appelle
ici la frontière il ya dix ans omar
amène la new wave veracruz où sud du
mexique avec sa mère pour émigrer aux
états unis
finalement le mur et les dangers de la
traversée les ont poussés à changer
d'avis et à s'installer à tijuana
aujourd'hui à 20 ans il est chauffeur de
taxi et début de sa carrière de boxeur
professionnel
[Musique]
je suis venu à tijuana pour aller aux
états unis mais je n'y suis pas arrivé
j'ai découvert la boxe et ça m'a plu
donneront moulleau m'a transmis envie de
réussir il me dit tout le temps que pour
devenir champion de boxe il ne faut pas
traîner dans la rue avoir de mauvaises
fréquentations être dans de mauvais plan
je remercie dans leur boulot et ses
enfants ils m'ont beaucoup donné
je les aime beaucoup parce qu'ici je
n'ai pas de père que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de respect pour lui
[Musique]
comme beaucoup raté est un entraîneur
légendaire
celui qui a mené julio cesar chavez à
conquérir son premier titre de champion
du monde en 1984 au gymnase créa au
coeur de tijuana l'enseignement de la
boxe créer du lien social c'est aussi
une alternative à l'exil
ici les jeunes se force d'une
personnalité autour d'un système de
valeurs fondé sur le travail et le
respect pour les jeunes c'est important
de pratiquer un sport n'importe lequel
ça les aide à trouver leur voie cette
école de boxe est reconnue à
l'international
c'est pour ça qu'il réussisse il ya une
qualité d'enseignement
ici nous improvisons rien nous sommes
des professionnels mais nous aimons
entraîner des enfants
j'aime travailler avec eux de leur plus
jeune âge ça me remplit ça me nourrit
c'est pour ça que je travaille ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
au mexique tijuana est devenue la
capitale de la boxe anglaise depuis les
années 80 cette villa formé 16 champions
du monde
les combats qui s'y déroulent constitue
un véritable tremplin vers la scène
internationale
[Applaudissements]
oh
ce soir miguel angel garcia dispute son
premier combat professionnel au gymnase
créé à entraîner pardonne romulo il a
côtoyé des grands de la boxe et toucher
du doigt un rêve qui le conduira
peut-être à traverser un jour la
frontière américaine par la grande porte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]